chilling new details about the capital
attack from last night's hearing of the
january 6 committee held in prime time
did you stay up like to watch it stay up
late to watch it there was plenty to see
we heard new evidence that former
president trump was in fact aware of the
violence and chose not to stop it now
that's despite threats against his vice
president that according to the
testimony last night prompted members of
his security detail to call loved ones
to say goodbye
scott mcfarlane is following all of this
for us on capitol hill scott good
morning to you
gail good morning the committee at its
latest hearing says trump stoked the
violence january 6 with his tweets and
then betrayed his oath of office by
willfully sitting silent watching
television as his supporters attacked
the capitol
donald trump's
conduct
on january 6
was a supreme violation of his oath of
office the house select committee
investigating january 6 argued thursday
night former president trump didn't fail
to act he chose deliberately not to stop
the riot within 15 minutes of leaving
the stage president trump knew that the
capital was besieged and under attack he
ignored pleas from his supporters in
congress as well as those in the white
house as we heard in the committee's
highly sought deposition from former
white house counsel pat cipolloni i
think i was pretty clear there need to
be an immediate
and forceful
response statement public statement that
people need to leave the capitol now
instead as the violence was well
underway the committee showed the
president sent a tweet at 2 24 p.m
accusing vice president pence of lacking
courage two former trump aides who quit
that day testified about their reaction
that was the moment that i decided that
i was going to resign that that would be
my last day at the white house uh i i
simply didn't want to be associated with
with the events that were unfolding on
the capitol in that moment for him to
tweet out the message about mike pence
it was him pouring gasoline on the fire
and making it much worse and there was
chilling new audio released listen as
the secret service tried to get then
vice president pence to safety
there's six
officers between us and the people that
are five to ten feet away from me and in
one of the darkest moments of the
hearing the committee played clips from
a white house security official whose
identity was concealed speaking about
how concerned vice president pence's
detail were for their own lives i'm not
talking about it but um
there were calls to
say goodbye to family members
it was getting
for whatever the reason was on the
ground the vp details thought that this
was about to get very unclean sarah
matthews the former white house press
aide described this exchange with her
boss kaylee mcenany about efforts urging
trump to condemn the violence she looked
directly at me and in a hushed tone
shared with me that the president did
not want to include any sort of mention
of peace in that tweet we also saw never
before publicly seen outtakes of trump
recording his remarks the day after
january 6. but this election is now over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election's over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
on january 7
one day after he incited an insurrection
based on a lie
president trump
still could not say that the election
was over after its eighth public hearing
the committee said there's more to come
we have considerably more to do doors
have opened new subpoenas have been
issued and the dam has begun to break
during the hearing we also heard from
the committee and we also heard from
former president trump who slammed the
committee on social media saying they
were making a fake case
meanwhile we've learned the internal
review of the department of homeland
security of those missing secret service
text messages could lead to criminal
charges and tony the committee revealed
there will be more public hearings here
in september
scott thank you very much